WRITTEN REQUEST TO REMOVE THEIR
NAMES FROM THE RECALL PETITION.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS SPOKE
TODAY WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
GUATEMALA, ONE OF THE PERSONS
ACTION SINCE SHE WAS PUT IN
CHARGE OF THE DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS
TO END THE MASSIVE IMMIGRATION
SURGE INTO THE U.S.
THIS COMES AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
RECEIVES AN INCREASING SHARE OF
THE BLAME FOR THE BORDER CRISIS.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY HAS DETAILS TONIGHT.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENTS EFFORT TO
STOP THE FLOW OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS INTO THE COUNTRY
TODAY A CHAT WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF GUATEMALA VIRTUALLY.
>> I AM HONORED TO MEET WITH YOU
AND LOOK FORWARD TO TRAVELING TO
GUATEMALA AND MEETING WITH YOU
IN PERSON AND CURRENTLY OUR PLAN
IS TO COME THERE IN THE MONTH
OF JUNE.
>> TAKEN THAT ZOOM CALL FROM HER
OFFICE AND STILL HAS NOT BEEN TO
THE BORDER BUT SAYS THAT SHE
WANTS TO.
>> YES, WE ARE WORKING ON THE
PLAN TO GET THERE, WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH COVID ISSUES.
>> NOT PREVENTING FROM TRAVELING
TO OTHER STATES, SO WAY IS THIS
DIFFERENT?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO ASK YOUR TEAM
ABOUT THAT SPECIFICALLY BUT I
WOULD TELL YOU ALL SO THAT HER
FOCUS IS NOT ON THE BORDER IT'S
ON ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES IN
THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
>> REPUBLICAN CRITICS AREN'T
BUYING THAT.
>> THAT'S THE EXCUSE THAT THIS
DEMONSTRATION IS GOING TO USE.
AND LOOK AT HER, SHE HAS BEEN
JET-SETTING AROUND THIS COUNTRY
GOING TO ALL THE DIFFERENT BLUE
STATES TALKING ABOUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO NO, THIS IS NOT COVID AND YOU
KNOW IT.
>> BORDER SECURITY IS WORSE
TODAY THAN IN 2018 ACCORDING TO
46% OF REGISTERED VOTERS IN THE
FOX NEWS POLL.
15% SAY BORDER SECURITY IS
BETTER AND 56% SAY THE ELECTION
IS EITHER COMPLETELY OR MOSTLY
THE REASON THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN MIGRANTS AT THE
BORDER AS A REPUBLICAN SAY HE IS
NOT REACHING OUT.
>> I HAVE NOT MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT ONE TIME OR HAD ONE
CONVERSATION WITH HIM.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE DOUBTS THAT'S
BREAKING THROUGH.
>> THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT HIM
NOT MEETING WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY.
>> TAKING CREDIT FOR MILESTONES
HE THINKS HE HAS REACHED
REPUBLICANS WANT HIM TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> WE HAVE A CRISIS AT A BORDER
THAT HE CREATED.
>> GOING TO BE LISTENING FOR ON
WEDNESDAY IN THE PRESIDENT'S
FIRST JOINT ADDRESS SESSION
REMARKS TO A JOINT SESSION OF
CONGRESS JEN PSAKI SAYS FOR THE
NEXT TWO DAYS THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO BE VERY INVOLVED IN
CRAFTING THAT SPEECH.
WE DID NOT SEE HIM ON -- IN
PERSON OR ON CAMERA TODAY A VERY
LIMITED NUMBER OF LAWMAKERS WILL
SEE HIM IN PERSON ON WEDNESDAY
NIGHTS BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
AND WE WANTED TO JUST ONE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE WILL BE IN
ATTENDANCE BECAUSE OF THAT
REASON IT WILL BE THE
CHIEF JUSTIC